Primero consideremos la expresión para,
la suma de 9 y el resultado de 4 veces "x".
A mi me gusta primero utilizar la parte que
tiene "x" y veamos...
El resultado de 4 veces "x" lo podemos
representar como, "4x",
a eso le sumaremos 9...
así es que pondremos con otro color más 9...
esta es la primera expresión que tenemos,
tenemos 4 veces "x" más 9. Ahora, selecciona la respuesta coincide con lo siguiente,
-1, tomaremos un -1, más el producto de -9, a eso le sumaremos el producto de -9 y esa expresión,
recuerda que cuando hablamos de producto estamos hablando de una multiplicación.
Así es que si tenemos -9 y esa expresión, significa que estaremos multiplicando -9
por la expresión que tenemos aquí arriba,
que será, "4x" más 9.
Ahora veamos cuales de estas respuestas coinciden con lo que tenemos.
Tenemos -9, eso es correcto, -9 por "4x" más 9 perfecto... menos 1.
Ok, esta respuesta parece adecuada, sin
embargo lo que hicieron aquí,
fue poner el -1 al final, para que tengamos
exactamente la misma expresión
vamos a mudar este -1 hacia la derecha y lo colocaremos aquí, -1 y eliminaremos éste.
Dejaremos entonces -9 por "4x" más 9 menos 1,
así es que esta respuesta se ve adecuada.
Veamos si las demás respuestas también son similares.
Tenemos 9 positivo, por "9x", de entrada aquí,
el 4 está multiplicando el "x" no el 9,
así es que eliminaremos ésta.
"4x" más 9 menos 1, parece similar, sin embargo
este es un +9 y nosotros tenemos un -9,
esta respuesta la eliminamos.
Y finalmente tenemos un "-4x" menos 9,
aquí tenemos ya los... este...
aquí tenemos ya este signo cambiado, +9,
-9 y aquí está restando -9, no multiplicando,
así es que, ésta tampoco será la respuesta.
Nos vamos entonces con esta respuesta, -9
por "4x" más 9
y a todo eso le restaremos 1, ésta será
la respuesta correcta.